I've never been much of a fighter
apologies for what you're about to see
hey youtubers is Charlie so surprise
surprise they drop to [ __ ] like an
extended clip for episode 1 it just add
some more context to what's going on
with Davos trying to fight off the rest
of the Nights Watch Kabul really awesome
things going on here 1 Davos is fighting
with long cloth meaning that even if he
weren't that great with a sword he would
be able to hack the other swords of the
Nights Watch two pieces favorite example
of a Valyrian sword versus a regular
sword is chopping through one of little
fingers guards swords just like it was
no big deal fair warning I'm gonna drop
a couple of f-bombs just because I'm
gonna talk about Ollie a little bit so
we have to talk about the special reddit
thread for Ollie so here we go this
scene is kind of like Davos versus Ollie
dawn of [ __ ] ollie because [ __ ] that guy
seriously
remember Ollie is the one who killed
Ygritte during season 4 it seems so long
ago you've almost forgotten it but that
was the beginning of the [ __ ] all a
reddit thread but I almost can't
remember if that didn't start to trend
till after the season 5 finale when he
kind of lured Jon Snow into that trap in
the books that went down a little
differently the giant one one had killed
one of the other Night's Watch
so they were retaliating for that Jon
Snow tried to stop them so for them that
was like the straw that broke the
camel's back they like ollie on the TV
show had been offended with his
treatment of the wildlings treating them
as equals being really nice to them
they didn't like that at all the show
really kind of put that all on Ollie the
show did have a couple scenes with
characters like Alliser thorne and his
supporters within the Nights Watch they
weren't really happy with the way they
were dealing with the wildlings but the
writers really did make Ollie the
mouthpiece of that they killed my family
how can you be helping them so much so
thus we arrive at [ __ ] Ollie
but even though in this scene he's kind
of standing in the background of this
crowd here do you think that the show
would kill him off do you think with
that innocent face of his give it all
the things that he's done they would
spare him I think we'd all love to see
ghosts turn him into a piece of beef
jerky
speaking of which we actually get a much
better shot of Ghost a frontal shot
because in the trailer they jumped over
him so quickly you couldn't tell whether
or not he was alive and I think most of
us assumed that he was just sitting
watch over Jon's body along with
Melisandre and Davos whatever they end
up doing with Ollie I definitely think
these two that are hacking the door down
are going to be the redshirts they'll be
the ones to get cut down first Alliser
Thorne is the big question mark too
because he's always hated Jon Snow but
he does believe in the tenants of the
Nights Watch he's just really stuck
the mud when it comes to wildlings my
initial thought here is is that half of
these wildlings end up going down with
the exception of Ollie and Alliser
thorne maybe couple others Jon Snow is
spared from being burned for a couple
more episodes then he comes back in
there so dumbstruck by what's happened
that they fall in line a lot of you guys
have asked me is to you know whether or
not Jon Snow is freed from his vows
because he's died so if he were to come
back he wouldn't have to be a member of
the Nights Watch anymore
even if that were true I don't think he
would take off I think he takes their
mission very seriously and he's seen
what is coming so he knows that if the
realm is gonna survive they are the last
defense he's also still a human being so
with all the chaos going on south of the
wall with the Bolton's I do think in his
head he would try to help his family but
the real question is do Jon Snow in the
Nights Watch come for the Bolton's first
or do the Bolton's make the first move
let me know how you think it's going to
go down because I definitely think
there's going to be a North remembers
storyline with Sansa she'll try to move
against the Bolton's then you also have
the wildlings Jon Snow and the Nights
Watch and then you have the Bolton's
with their supporters too so the big
ward that they've been teasing seems
like it's mostly going to be localized
to the north although they'll be big
conflicts going on all over the place
it's just that when you talk about big
pitched battle most of that's going to
be happening in the north it seems like
if you didn't see the Tower of joy video
that I posted yesterday they also
announced that episode 1 is titled the
red woman now obviously that refers to
Melisandre but usually titles are
metaphorical they apply to all the
storylines that are going on so the red
woman could also apply to Cersei as in
Lannister red there's also a new red
priestess that they cast for the eastern
storyline so they'll be one that will
show up around Daenerys but above all
else when you think red woman you think
Melisandre and because Melisandre is
standing here next to Jon Snow's body
she's gonna experience a dramatic
turnaround but no I don't think that Jon
Snow is gonna be coming back to life in
the first episode I think they want to
hold on to that as long as possible so
let me know in the comments which
episode do you think that he's going to
come roaring back in I'll say definitely
before episode 5 I'd be really surprised
if he came back before episode 3
depending on how fast things move I
think it's most likely to be like
episode 4 but he can totally come back
in episode 2 I'll just I'll be shouting
extra loud if it happens though quick
reminder there is a new round of the
giveaway that's going on now all you
have to do to enter
be a subscriber and leave a comment on
this video this is really unexpected so
I'm still doing another game of Thrones
bonus video on Sunday if you have any
special requests for that just leave
them in the comments really surprised
HBO dropped this extended clip they
always change the way they market the
show each year I can't remember if they
were dropping full scenes like this last
year usually in terms of footage it's
like a couple big trailers and then a
couple smaller teasers and I do think
sometime in the next week or two we will
get another proper trailer like one
final big trailer just in case you
haven't seen it you can click here for
the Tower of joy teaser that I posted
yesterday it's kind of like the
spanish-language video so I added some
subtitles and you can click here for my
season 6 trailer breakdown thank you so
much for watching everybody
let's at 5 I'll see you guys tonight
you